[Música]
es prioritario que se cierre guantánamo
fue una de las conclusiones
ni aulen la relatora especial de la ONU
sobre la promoción y protección de los
derechos humanos y las libertades en la
lucha contra el terrorismo Es la primera
vez que un experto de Naciones Unidas
visita este centro de detención que
Estados Unidos tiene en la Bahía
homóloga ubicada en Cuba la enviada
especial la relatora afirmó que tuvo
acceso total a las instalaciones y que
habló con detenidos considerados como de
alto valor y también como los de no tan
alto valor y si bien reconoció mejoras
significativas en las condiciones de
reclusión dijo tener serias
preocupaciones por los 30 hombres que
siguen detenidos y que según ella
enfrentan daños físicos y psicológicos
por las torturas y otras violaciones de
Derechos Humanos que han tenido dentro
de la prisión
este informe defiende los derechos de
las víctimas del terrorismo a la
justicia a la rendición de cuentas y a
la transparencia pero encuentro que la
Barrera más significativa para el
cumplimiento de los derechos de las
víctimas y sobrevivientes fue el uso de
la tortura la tortura fue una traición a
los derechos de las víctimas de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre el
gobierno de Estados Unidos debe brindar
urgentemente resolución judicial
disculpas y garantías de no repetición
Estados Unidos respondió con una carta
resaltando que la posición de la
relatora especial no refleja la visión
de la ONU como tal agregó que durante la
administración de Joe biden se ha
transferido a diez detenidos a otras
cárceles y negó algunas violaciones
humanitarias mencionadas por la
diplomática en su reporte final
Estados Unidos no está de acuerdo con
aspectos significativos de muchas
afirmaciones fácticas y de derecho que
ha realizado la relatora especial
estamos comprometidos con brindar un
trato seguro y humano a los detenidos en
guantánamo en total conformidad con el
derecho internacional y el derecho
interno de Estados Unidos los detenidos
viven en comunidad y preparan comidas
juntos reciben atención médica y
psiquiátrica especializada se les da
pleno acceso a la asesoría legal y se
comunican regularmente con sus
familiares tanto Joe biden como el
expresidente demócrata Barack Obama
prometieron cerrar guantánamo bajo sus
administraciones alegando que el centro
de detención socava el liderazgo que
tiene Estados Unidos en materia de
Derechos Humanos Obama incluso firmó una
orden ejecutiva en el segundo día de su
presidencia ordenando el cierre sin
embargo ni con esto ni con sus múltiples
pronunciamientos al respecto se terminó
guantánamo
Le pedí a mi equipo que se revise todo
lo que se está haciendo actualmente en
guantánamo todo lo que podemos hacer
administrativamente y voy a volver a
comprometerme con el congreso para
tratar de demostrar que esto no es algo
que beneficia a la gente
[Aplausos]
con el final de la guerra afgana este
debe ser el año en que el congreso
levante las restricciones restantes
sobre los traslados de detenidos y
cerremos la prisión de la Bahía de
guantánamo
hoy el departamento está presentando al
congreso nuestro plan para finalmente
cerrar las instalaciones en guantánamo
de una vez por todas por el contrario
siendo presidente Donald Trump en 2018
firmó otra orden ejecutiva para revertir
la decisión de Obama y mantener
guantánamo abierta para el republicano
los terroristas deben ser tratados como
tal y terminar con la prisión era una
señal de debilidad se debe cerrar o no
guantánamo Cómo debe ser el balance
entre la guerra contra el terrorismo
bajo la cual se inauguró la cárcel en
2001 y los derechos humanos de los
detenidos hoy en el debate para discutir
estos temas estamos con César Muñoz
directora asociado del departamento de
América Latina y el Caribe de Human
Rights watch quien está en Sao Paulo y
desde Maine Estados Unidos nos acompaña
Erick rojo Coronel retirado del ejército
de este país y experto en temas
militares y de seguridad nacional a los
dos Gracias por acompañarnos y a nos
están viendo y nos están escuchando Los
invito a que dejen sus comentarios en
las redes sociales con el hashtag el
debate f24 nos pueden seguir también en
Twitter Facebook e Instagram donde
estamos como arroba franz24-raya al piso
es y a mí me encuentran como arroba
mariacle Aguirre quiero saludar
especialmente a quienes nos están
escuchando en nuestro podcast a través
de las plataformas de Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar entonces con César Muñoz
Gracias por acompañarnos en este debate
César la visión general suya sobre este
reporte de la ONU y Esta visita de la
relatora especial
Muchas gracias mire nosotros creemos que
este informe de la Primero Esta visita
de la relatora es muy importante ha
tardado muchísimo como han dicho Es la
primera vez que una especialista de la
ONU tiene este acceso a la prisión y a
los detenidos en guantánamo y y es muy
importante porque refleja el continuado
abuso de Derechos Humanos en guantánamo
y el impacto que eso tiene No solo en
las personas que están allí sino en la
defensa de Derechos Humanos en el mundo
y como esta Digamos como el
mantenimiento de esta política al final
es una tradición contra las víctimas
creo que eso es muy importante que ella
dijo porque esas víctimas no están
viendo justicia por lo que ocurrió en
los atentados del 11 de septiembre las
personas que están que son sus puestos
responsables de de esa de esa masacre
deberían ser juzgadas eso que las
familias quieren y en cambio están en
guantánamo en un limbo legal sin que
haya juicios
ahora Eric rojo quiero seguir con usted
Bienvenido al debate de France 24 Cuál
es su opinión general de este reporte
el reporte es absurdo en primer lugar
las Naciones Unidas no tienen por qué
meterse en lo que no les importa
y se les dio la visita de cortesía
sabiendo que
van a decir las cosas que siempre dicen
que no tienen nada que ver con una
realidad de castigar a los terroristas
evitar que los terroristas sigan
haciendo su función aquellos que fueron
dados en libertad regresaron a las filas
del talibán así es que no debemos
hacernos ninguna ilusión que estas
personas tienen ningún valor para un
mundo real y que las víctimas realmente
están sufriendo las víctimas de las
familias porque las víctimas están todas
muertas No necesariamente quieren verlos
en libertad ni quieren ver los que se
traten mejor el problema con las
Naciones Unidas en este caso y Human
Rights w no es la primera vez que
tenemos la la oportunidad de compartir
opiniones se dedican exclusivamente a
proteger a los criminales y nunca a las
víctimas yo acabo de regresar de varios
años en México y es la misma situación
se dedica a proteger a los criminales a
los carteles y los pobres víctimas a
nadie le importan Bueno pero más allá de
dirigir el ataque de Human quiero que
nos concentremos y quiero que
concentremos este debate sobre
guantánamo y sobre el más reciente
reporte de la relatora especial de la
ONU usted lo califica Erick como un
reporte absurdo y dice además que
guantánamo está para castigar a
terroristas sobre este último punto
Quiero preguntarle algo y es que en
guantánamo se ha conocido que hay tres
niveles para clasificar a los detenidos
dependiendo del riesgo que significan
para la seguridad nacional
estadounidense Y estos tres niveles Son
bajo medio y alto y según los cerca de
800 documentos que publicó Wikileaks en
2011 documentos de seguridad nacional
estadounidense la mayoría Dentro de este
periodo dentro de los primeros años
hasta 2008 se libraron acerca de 200
prisioneros de los ciento de los 780 que
han pasado por esta cárcel y la mayoría
de ellos según estos documentos
oficiales eran catalogados como de bajo
riesgo y realmente muchos de ellos ni
siquiera tenían que ver con el ataque
del 9/11 del 11 ese del 11 de septiembre
y esto también es lo que ha dicho humain
rates watch la mayoría de los detenidos
no han estado directamente involucrados
en esos ataques terroristas en ese
sentido como entonces cataloga usted a
todos los detenidos como terroristas
porque en algún caso en sus funciones
después de la invasión de Afganistán se
descubrió que sus actividades eran
terroristas y se sacaron del país para
tratarlos los que no tenían culpabilidad
se soltaron los que como dices
correctamente no representaban un riesgo
mayor se han soltado Entonces
el catalista fueron los ataques del 11
de septiembre pero el apoyo a los grupos
terroristas el apoyo al talibán
concluye muchas cosas más allá que
solamente el ataque del 11 de septiembre
y como en todas presiones hay diferentes
niveles de riesgo de prisioneros eso no
no es nada extraordinario en guantánamo
es una cárcel Precisamente en territorio
donde vuela la bandera americana algunos
de los juicios no se han podido llevar
en territorio Estados Unidos porque los
estados y las jurisdicciones no se
consideran capaces legalmente obtienen
el interés de llevar a cabo los juicios
Así es que los juicios que se han
llevado se siguen llevando ahí en
guantánamo si son juicios militares Pero
como dijo el reporte los prisioneros
tienen derecho tienen apoyo legal tanto
de este abogados militares como civiles
se siguen llevando los casos Este pero
siguen siendo terroristas eso no cambia
César quiero ir con usted para darle la
oportunidad de Que responda un poco a lo
de Erick y le quiero Añadir una pregunta
y es la posición como lo dije
previamente de Trump y de algunos
republicanos es se necesita un centro de
detención para castigar a los
terroristas de ataques tan dolorosos
para Estados Unidos como el 11 de
septiembre como justificar entonces
guantánamo
mire en respuesta a los comentarios que
ha hecho el señor rojo en humans
defendemos el estado de derecho Ese es
el camino para combatir la delincuencia
en México o el terrorismo en cualquier
otro país Estados Unidos ha juzgado a
más de 700 terroristas y los ha
condenado desde el 11 de septiembre en
territorio estadounidense yo estuve por
ejemplo en la primera audiencia de
calypsis muhamma que está acusado de ser
el arquitecto de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre en Estados Unidos fui
aguantando a esa audiencia fue hace 15
años fue hace 15 años y todavía no ha
habido juicio contra esa persona ese es
el problema de guantánago es un vacío
legal una creación de Estados Unidos
para castigar a personas ciertamente los
están castigando pero sin ningún tipo de
juicio antes las personas que cometen un
crimen y crímenes como los que los
ataques terroristas tienen que pagar por
ello pero tiene que ser según las leyes
No eso es fundamental lo que ha hecho
Estados Unidos ha sido absolutamente
contraproducente porque guantánamo se ha
convertido en un símbolo de abusos en el
mundo se ha convertido en se ha usado
como un panfleto de terror grupos
terroristas en el mundo para reclutar a
nuevos terroristas diciendo miren lo que
está ocurriendo en guantánamo Estados
Unidos Mire lo que están haciendo O sea
en términos incluso de política externa
ha sido un desastre para Estados Unidos
por eso es necesario que se cierre es
necesario que se cierre y que vuelva a
la legalidad Eric para seguir utilizando
Este ejemplo que nos trae César
Mohamed rememoremos un poco que él fue
acusado precisamente por los atentados
del 11 de septiembre y Fue capturado en
2003 sin embargo ahora entre junio y
Julio se Está realizando en guantánamo
lo que en inglés se conoce como el trial
o todos los procedimientos previos al
juicio es decir ha estado encerrado y
encarcelado 20 años y todavía no se le
ha acusado o no ha tenido una condena
Ahí es donde César habla de un vacío
legal Usted cree que hay un vacío legal
en guantánamo
no hay ningún pasión legal Sencillamente
y lo dirige lo diré desde un punto de
vista de militares ciudadano americano
yo no tengo prisa en que esto se haga
esos señores son culpables
nos cambiaron el mundo Más allá de lo
que todo mundo quiere aceptar porque
realmente el mundo completo ha cambiado
a raíz de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre los abusos de tener que hacer
Colas en los aeropuertos en todo el
mundo las
excesivas en medidas de seguridad todo
esto se los debemos a estos señores Así
es que digo yo no tengo por qué tocarme
el corazón con ellos y este
Le tocará su día Le tocará pero no hay
prisa no hay prisa Pero usted dice que
son culpables Cómo tratarlos de
culpables si ni siquiera han tenido un
juicio y existe la máxima en el derecho
internacional que nadie es culpable
hasta que se demuestra lo contrario
esa máxima es correcta pero volvemos a
un punto muy simple sabemos de su
culpabilidad sabemos que es un riesgo si
se suelta eventualmente tendrá el juicio
y el juicio lo llevará a su destino
final que espero sea la pena de muerte
pero mientras tanto estos años en
prisión le da motivo de pensar a sus
motivaciones de asesinar a tantos
ciudadano inocente que es realmente lo
que sucedió y los efectos que ha tenido
ese ataque terrorista en el mundo
César quiero regresar con usted sobre un
punto que señala Eric y es sabemos que
si los soltamos ellos volverán a actos
terroristas y hay un caso reiterado y
que ha sido mencionado en Estados Unidos
de manera reiterada y es el caso de abu
Back albahadí que fue el fundador del
estado islámico en Siria y en Irak que
fue detenido por las fuerzas
estadounidenses y durante diez meses en
Irak lo detuvieron y luego lo soltaron y
después de eso fundó el estado islámico
en Irak y en Siria Cómo responder
entonces a esto
Mira la propuesta que está haciendo el
señor Erick es una propuesta dictatorial
es decir el estado decide Quién es
culpable todos sabemos que es culpable
es el argumento y entonces pues lo
dejamos allá y no hay ninguna prisa o
sea eso es lo que se hacía en la Edad
Media y eso no ayuda en nada a yo creo
que no ayuda nada a combatir el
terrorismo como digo eso se convierte en
un punto de propaganda para grupos
terroristas en el mundo
entonces hay que aplicar la legalidad
y la legalidad significa una persona que
es detenida tiene que ser juzgada tiene
que tener los cargos Y ser juzgada y si
no hay cargos la tiene que poner en
libertad de las 30 personas que hay en
guantánamo ahora 19 no tienen cargos o
sea supuestamente son culpables pero no
hay cargos contra ellos ni siquiera
ahora es posible que usted en un juicio
en una situación
se libere una persona y vuelva a
delinquir eso ocurre realmente
desgraciadamente ocurre es la verdad
puede ocurrir en Estados Unidos en
cualquier momento en cualquier tribunal
Pero eso si ese es el argumento Entonces
no se puede soltar a nadie en ningún
momento o sea es una cosa que realmente
socaba el estado de derecho al final le
cambio la pregunta Entonces si esta
manera de operar en guantánamo según
usted socava el derecho internacional y
los Derechos Humanos Por qué durante las
administraciones demócratas no se cerró
guantánamo
bueno eso se lo tiene que preguntar a
los gobiernos demócratas no obviamente
es muy difícil no es no es fácil y
realmente fue es una situación que nunca
debería haberse dado Realmente las
personas que fueron detenidas en el
extranjero donde
con evidencia o sospecha de que estaban
envueltos en ataques terroristas contra
Estados Unidos debían haberse jugado en
Estados Unidos como se han juzgado a más
de 700 personas en los últimos 20 años
por terrorismo Y condenados estos 700 No
ahora Estamos en esta situación que
realmente es muy complicada y Nuestra
llamada Es que se cierre guantánamo
sabemos que no va a ser mañana que es un
proceso pero se pueden tomar medidas
ahora por ejemplo una medida muy
importante es que haya juicios justos
estas comisiones
militares estos tribunales militares no
han funcionado o sea ha habido cuando yo
estuve en aquella audiencia en 2008 esa
audiencia duró 10 minutos porque
inmediatamente
hubo
discrepancias sobre el las reglas sobre
las leyes porque sé que intentó crear un
sistema alternativo de Justicia no tiene
que ser aplicada a la ley la ley
estadounidense y las personas que son
culpables deben cumplir una pena
usted habla de un sistema alternativo de
Justicia ahí quiero que profundicemos
con Eric Pero antes hacer una precisión
Y es que Estados Unidos tiene el control
jurisdiccional sobre la Bahía de
guantánamo que queda en Cuba A pesar de
que Estados Unidos reconoce la soberanía
sobre ese territorio del gobierno cubano
Esto se debe a un pacto que hicieron los
dos países en 1903 en el que acceden a
que Estados Unidos tenga el control
sobre ese territorio y es allí donde
monta su base naval y dentro de esta
base naval monta la prisión Esto fue un
poco un intercambio que hicieron los
cubanos con los estadounidenses a cambio
del apoyo estadounidense para que Cuba
luchará por su independencia contra los
españoles y de allí se debe el poder que
tiene Estados Unidos entonces a pesar de
que es un territorio soberano que le
pertenece a los cubanos los
estadounidenses se comprometieron a
pagar una mensualidad por ese territorio
y tienen
jurisdiccional sobre guantánamo sin
embargo allí no se ha aplicado la ley
estadounidense y de hecho la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
resaltó la importancia de que sí se
aplicara y dijo en su reporte de 2015
que un poco lo que había hecho Estados
Unidos era trasladar a los prisioneros
que deseaba a guantánamo para huir de la
jurisdicción de Estados Unidos y sin
embargo 7 años después de creada esta
cárcel los jueces estadounidenses
dijeron No hasta allí También se deben
aplicar las leyes estadounidenses Eric
se están aplicando o no y si se
estuvieran aplicando Por qué hay tantas
denuncias de torturas e incluso muertos
dentro de guantánamo
Mira la ley se está aplicando y cuando
se aplica la ley militar algo que la
mayoría de las personas no saben Es que
la Constitución de Estados Unidos
establece la ley militar la ley militar
está aprobada por el congreso de Estados
Unidos no es algo extrajudicial ni que
existe
independiente del Congreso el congreso
Toma las decisiones finales en relación
a la ley ninguno de estos casos que yo
sepa se ha llevado a la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos por lo tanto no se ha
llevado un caso que lo considere de una
violación a la Constitución de Estados
Unidos Sencillamente estas son
reacciones emocionales de aquellos que
consideran que estamos llevando la
justicia de la manera en que no les
gusta o que quieren liberar a los
terroristas al igual que les encanta
liberar a los criminales internacionales
pero realmente el pueblo de Estados
Unidos está contento en general y
aceptando por medio del Congreso que
esto se está haciendo lo correcto
queremos historia fuera de jurisdicción
los juicios de nuremberg las leyes de
inventaron después de los crímenes
crímenes horribles se llevaron a cabo y
nadie se quejó porque se hizo en
cuestión de de unos pocos años aquí es
una situación diferente Pero no se ha
roto la legalidad de las leyes de
Estados Unidos y el hecho de que sea
territorio cubano reconocido siempre y
cuando la bandera de Estados Unidos esté
en ese territorio tiene territorialidad
nacional y la jurisdicción legal es de
Estados Unidos
tengo una contrapregunta para usted
señor Erick usted habla de que son
reacciones emocionales y de que no se
rompe la legalidad si esto es cierto
Entonces por qué la relatora de la ONU
habla de torturas sistemáticas detención
arbitraria y resalta lo que ya otros
organismos internacionales han hablado
estas torturas sobre todo uno de los
famosos métodos que es el waterboard o
el submarino en el que le ponen a los
detenidos un trapo sobre la cabeza y le
comienzan a echar agua para incitarlo al
ahogamiento
bueno en primer lugar hablamos de la
leyes Internacionales La Ley
internacional tiene una situación muy
interesante solamente las obedecen quien
quiere no hay jurisdirección y no hay
obligatoriedad en las leyes
internacionales entonces eso se vuelve
un discurso porque no tiene la capacidad
de llevarse a Cabo pero suena suena muy
bonito para todos aquellos que hablen de
la ley internacional Pero la realidad es
que cada país se acomoda a la ley
internacional según mejor le conviene y
son las organizaciones como la como Oro
que lo usan como un escudo para llevar a
cabo sus agendas
el que haya habido tortura es posible no
lo dudo yo estoy seguro que ya no se
lleva a cabo ya no es necesario
Sencillamente la detención de estas
personas va a seguir hasta qué momento
en que las nacionales decidan o llevar a
cabo los juicios soltarlos o lo que lo
que vaya a hacer pero Sencillamente esto
no va a cambiar la prisión no se va a
cerrar los prisioneros no se van a
soltar no importa quién sea presidente
de Estados Unidos usted dice Erick que
el derecho internacional humanitario lo
obedece un poco quien quiere Y supongo
que usted hace alusión al estatuto de
Roma que es el que rige el derecho
internacional humanitario y estatuto de
Roma que Estados Unidos no ratificó no
hace parte César en este sentido
Entonces qué obliga o que no obliga a
Estados Unidos a respetar el derecho
internacional humanitario en este caso
concreto las torturas
Sí mire
primero señora Eric dice que las leyes
de Estados Unidos se cumplen en
guantánamo Entonces
tenemos una situación donde hay personas
en guntano que llevan 20 años sin un
juicio y personas sin ser acusadas de
ningún delito eso es imposible en
Estados Unidos O sea una persona que
esté 20 años detenida en cualquier lugar
en Estados Unidos
sin juicio o sea eso es ilegal o sea
claramente la situación que está en
guantánamo no se ajusta las leyes
estadounidenses
el hecho de que ha habido tortura de que
hay según la relatora continúa habiendo
maltrato de las personas que están allí
muestra que no se está aplicando la ley
estadounidense sobre el derecho
internacional el derecho internacional
al contrario que el señor Eric dice sí
es obligatorio
y está basado en los tratados que un
país firma las Estados Unidos firma el
tratado por ejemplo de derechos
políticos y civiles tiene que cumplir
ese tratado porque se compromete no y ha
sido ratificado por el congreso entonces
va el derecho internacional va más allá
del estatuto de Roma y una serie de
tratados internacionales que Estados
Unidos ha afirmado y que tiene que
cumplir y tratados que que establecen
una base mínima de tratamiento de las
personas en el sistema de justicia y eso
tiene que ser cumplido en guantánamo y
en cualquier lugar
Pero entonces si hay obligación por
parte de Estados Unidos a no torturar a
los presos por qué lo hace y por qué lo
ha hecho durante 21 años en guantánamo
Según dice el reporte
mire Me parece que esa política el
programa de la silla de torturas fue un
error inmenso de Estados Unidos
que solo ha dado munición a los enemigos
de Estados Unidos que es citado por
Rusia por china
por Egipto o sea gobiernos autoritarios
usan esos hechos porque está comprobado
que que hubo esas torturas para decir
bueno nosotros
podemos hacer lo mismo o rechazar las
críticas de Estados Unidos cuando
critica los abusos de Rusia por ejemplo
Entonces digamos en términos de política
externa ha sido un error enorme que ha
socavado la reputación de Estados Unidos
el derecho internacional la protección
de los derechos humanos
y lo que tiene que hacer los Estados
Unidos es lo contrario es defender
el derecho internacional defender los
derechos humanos eso le a Estados Unidos
a que no le ayuda a son a los gobiernos
autoritarios Pero entonces siempre hay
una crítica hacia los gobiernos
autoritarios usted menciona Rusia por
ejemplo y sobre Rusia ha caído toda
clase de sanciones económicas y
políticas Pero entonces cuál es la
responsabilidad o quién puede hacer
responsable a Estados Unidos O si tiene
Carta abierta para continuar guantánamo
mire el derecho internacional es de
obligado de cumplimiento obligado pero
no existe
una fuerza militar una fuerza policial
que va a obligar a un país a cumplirlo
eso es la realidad no y no y no existe
para obligar a Estados Unidos como no
existe para obligar a a otros países que
también tienen violaciones de Derechos
Humanos en realidad
es muy importante por ejemplo el trabajo
de la relatora en el sentido de que da
luz a lo que estaba oculto o sea de que
muestra
lo que estaba ocurriendo en guantánamo y
Abre una conversación y una presión
internacional sobre Estados Unidos que
es
legítima y ayuda no es así como funciona
o sea no tenemos un gobierno mundial que
va a imponer el derecho por la fuerza
Eric quiero regresar con usted usted
anteriormente decía que en guantánamo se
castigan a los terroristas y que esto
justifica no solamente su apertura sino
que siga funcionando pero tengo una
pregunta y es Entonces por qué otros
calificados y condenados por terrorismo
por ejemplo por la masacre de Boston han
sido condenados en Estados Unidos y no
en guantánamo
porque en primer lugar esos actos fueron
dentro del territorio de Estados Unidos
y perpetuado por ellos ellos no los
planearon de fuera del país lo planearon
dentro del país y lo ejecutaron ahí y el
ejemplo de Boston que pones es perfecto
son dos jóvenes que vivían ahí Y
decidieron poner las bombas que
autorizaron el maratón de Boston Ahora
quiero regresar a la cuestión de la
obligatoriedad de la ley internacional
Estados Unidos nunca va a firmar ningún
tratado internacional que permita que
otro país venga y nos diga Cómo podemos
o no podemos hacer las cosas Entonces
los tratados que firmamos los firmamos
voluntariamente para llevar a cabo su
cumplimiento dentro de nuestro propio
control los tratados que no firmamos
son aquellos que requieren que un
tercero venga a meterse en los asuntos
internos de Estados Unidos y como dice
el colega es muy importante aunque no se
lleve a cabo la ley internacional no hay
ningún mecanismo que Force a nadie a
cumplirla Entonces es retórico y yo no
vi que esta dama con las Naciones Unidas
trajera pruebas trajo anécdotas
trajo fotos trajo testimonio no
Sencillamente
oímos un testimonio emocional cuando se
le dio la oportunidad de visitar pero si
tiene que hablar de tortura Yo quiero
ver las pruebas pero las pruebas ya se
han visto
son del pasado no del presente la
tortura se llevó Y como dice Carlos fue
un error muy grande no se debían de
haber llevado a cabo este y en eso estoy
de acuerdo No necesitamos la tortura
Pero eso no quiere decir que aún se esté
llevando a cabo es muy diferente se
llevan o no a cabo torturas actualmente
en guantánamo César Bueno yo no lo sé
porque no he estado recientemente lo que
sabemos es este documento de esta
relatora que es una persona
independiente
escogida en el ámbito de la ONU para
hacer este tipo de informes y las hacen
todo el mundo O sea ella va a viajar
viaja a otros países y hace el mismo
tipo de investigación y es un es un
documento importante que están basado lo
que ella vio y los documentos a los que
ya tuvo acceso allí y las entrevistas
con los con los detenidos
obviamente lo ideal es que este material
que ya recogió se presente en un juicio
o sea se presente en el sistema criminal
porque se puede dudar de si es verdad o
no Para eso está el sistema de justicia
y ahí volvemos al mismo problema no que
estas personas que están en guantánamo
están sujetas a reglas legales jurídicas
que fueron creadas por Estados Unidos en
el momento con estas comisiones
especiales que que no existen en ningún
otro lugar Si ten solo en guantánamo
para juzgar a estos detenidos solo y que
no han tenido éxito que hemos visto los
juicios en Estados Unidos contra
terroristas personas que mataron a
inocentes en Estados Unidos en Boston y
también en Nueva York quien Washington
hubo es esas muertes por qué no puede
haber esos juicios en Estados Unidos eso
es lo que debería hacerse y hay otra
cara de estos juicios que señala la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos y la ONU y por lo que le quiero
preguntar a Eric y ellos dicen que hay
una discriminación ya que todos los 780
presos que han estado en guantánamo han
sido hombres musulmanes extranjeros Cómo
responder ante esto Erick
Sencillamente Porque todos los
criminales terroristas en este caso han
sido hombres extranjeros y musulmanes
Pero no por eso se le selecciona
Sencillamente es Quiénes son ellos no ha
habido ningún otro dentro de la
actividad de al qaida de este y del
grupo de ozono que no fuesen hombres
musulmanes y de algún tipo de de alguno
de los nacionales Entonces no tiene nada
que ver con discriminación Sencillamente
es una realidad y regreso al proceso de
nuremberg se hicieron leyes
postfacto para poder juzgar a los
criminales alemanes que hicieron tanto
mal al mundo Entonces la creación de una
ley posáculo si queremos decir en este
caso ya tiene precedente aceptado por
todo el mundo cuando se aceptaron tanto
Los juicios en Japón como en Alemania
pero si no hay discriminación que pasa
entonces con estos hombres musulmanes
extranjeros que eran inocentes y que
precisamente soltaron Por no tener
ninguna pruebas
Sencillamente cuando no hubo pruebas Se
le soltó pero no tiene nada que ver ni
con su religión ni con su nacionalidad
ni su género
César muy brevemente su comentario al
respecto para acercarnos a las
conclusiones
Bueno en realidad lo que Estados Unidos
creó aquí es
se inventó una ficción legal para buscar
un lugar en el mundo donde decía que
ninguna ley se aplicaba y hacer justicia
como quería o no hacer justicia porque
en realidad no lo ha hecho pero mantener
a personas en detención de forma
indefinida Sin dar respuesta a las
víctimas ni ni a los familiares de las
personas que tienen seres queridos Y que
hubiesen querido ver un juicio y que las
personas sean condenadas y que y que y
que cumplan su pena Según la ley no y en
cambio Tenemos aquí a personas muchas de
ellas que han sufrido tortura
y que siguen en esta detención
indefinida
y yo recuerdo cuando cuando estuve en
guantánamo que leí el informe del
Congreso de Estados Unidos sobre los
atentados del 11 de septiembre Y me
sorprendió que había muchísima evidencia
o sea uno Lee ese informe las personas
con han leído van a ver toda la
evidencia que existe contra esas
personas pues juzguenlas y no las tengan
ahí en un lugar que que realmente es un
sinónimo de abuso en el mundo entero
César muy brevemente en menos de 30
segundos su conclusión sobre guantánamo
y la visita de la relatora especial
Mire yo creo que aguantaron lo tiene que
cerrarse es una mancha en la reputación
de Estados Unidos cuando Estados Unidos
habla que defiende los derechos humanos
en el mundo que defiende las libertades
cualquiera le va a apuntar con el dedo y
decir pero ahí guantánamo eso lo hacen
todo el tiempo los gobiernos represivos
del mundo Entonces no le ayuda a Estados
Unidos ni ni le ayuda al mundo Eric y su
conclusión
Bueno luego que no tomaste el tema de
porque no te gusta la comparación Y si
están realmente dependiendo a las
víctimas que han hecho por las víctimas
de los terroristas no los comparé Porque
nuremberg si hubo juicios y porque
estábamos hablando de una Segunda Guerra
Mundial y también sobre nuremberg hay
todo un debate abierto y demasiada
literatura al respecto que en este
debate se nos acaba el tiempo César
Muñoz y Erick rojo Gracias por
acompañarnos la producción de este
programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés
doncell y la de los invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera Siguen con Franz 24
[Música]